- [Voiceover] Welcome to
Official SAT Practice.
Khan Academy and the
College Board have teamed up
to create the only SAT practice tool
developed with the
experts who write the SAT.
It's personalized for each student.
Available any time, anywhere,
and completely free.
We'll create personalized
practice recommendations for you.
Based on your test
results from the PSAT89,
PSAT10,
PSATMMSQT,
and SAT.
If you haven't already
taken a College Board test
you can take our short diagnostic
quizzes to get started.
Your practice plan will show
you where you already excel
and where you should focus your practice.
We'll also create a
practice schedule for you
based on your test date.
We have tons of interactive
practice questions
developed with the College Board
that give you instant
feedback on your answers.
As well as hints, and videos
to help you master your skills.
Mini sections help you
practice under time pressure.
We have official practice
tests written by the
College Board.
Taking at least two practice tests
will help you build the
experience and endurance
necessary to do well on test day.
Join more than one million
students already using
Official SAT Practice.
- Khan Academy was probably the best way
that I can use the study.
My math was below par.
Using Khan Academy built it up.
It improved my scores dramatically.
- I like the leveling up.
It kind of makes it a game.
- I feel excited and prepared
because it's something that
I've already seen, I've
already read through it.
So, when I take it I'm gonna do it well.
- [Voiceover] Sign up
and get started today
at satpractice.org.